I hear in Europe the country with the
most coronavirus cases Spain has now
surpassed 25,000 deaths but the number
of new infections is on the decline and
the country's begun easing some of its
strict lockdown measures for seven weeks
only one person per household was
allowed to leave their homes to go
grocery shopping or walk the dog but
starting today Spaniards are allowed to
go outside to exercise again I'll be
I'll be it while still under
restrictions a celebration of freedom in
Madrid starting today
Spaniards can leave their homes to
exercise something they haven't been
able to do in nearly two months it's
part of the country's roadmap to
recovery we feel free it's essential for
physical and mental health it's
essential to allow people to exercise
everyone does what they want if people
want to catch it let them catch it but
this will mean that in 15 or 20 days
we'll be locked up at home again I feel
great there are very tough restrictions
but it is what it is we have to follow
the instructions from the Health
Ministry because they know more than us
this feeling of freedom is great when
this all gets better all of us will feel
even better in a bid to avoid
overcrowding the government has
implemented a shift system adults can
exercise mornings and evenings
afternoons are earmarked for children
with the remaining time slots reserved
for the elderly authorities are
monitoring the situation closely with
the highest number of cases in Europe
Spain has the continents largest
coronavirus field hospital in another
positive sign it's finally closing its
doors
the last patients left the facility on
Friday much to the relief of the medical
staff as Spain takes its first steps
forward the rest of Europe is watching
closely joining me now from Sevilla in
southern Spain is correspondent Yun
Philip Schultz Yun Philip Spain has had
really strict lockdown rules the past
few weeks what's the feeling there now
that they're being eased it's a very
good feeling personally I've been in a
privileged situation as a journalist I
was allowed to move more or less freely
and there were also certain relaxations
for parents and their children but for a
lot of people today is really the first
time in 7 weeks that they have been able
to to leave their apartments and as you
can see behind me it's a very beautiful
day it's a sunny day and there are a lot
of people enjoying life outside on the
streets so many people in fact that in
some regions officials have already
warned of overcrowding but of course
there are still a lot of restrictions in
place we have heard about the different
shifts the different time slots for
different age groups but there's also a
one-kilometer radios restriction and a
lot of people have started to download
apps to show them where exactly they can
go within the one kilometer radius well
we understand that today's move is part
of a comprehensive road map really to
ease lockdown measures what are the next
steps that the Spanish government is
planning exactly this is just the first
step of a comprehensive plan of four
phases that the government calls the
tradition the transition to a new
normality but Prime Minister Sanchez has
stressed that it's a gradual and
asymmetrical process as he calls it
meaning that in different regions there
can be different speeds according to the
infection rates and capacities but what
is for sure is that in mid-may there
will be restaurants that can open part
of their auto facilities again and
probably by mid June
Spaniards will be allowed to travel all
over the country again Yann Philip
Schultz speaking to us from Spain thanks
very much for your insight